[Music]
Eleanore
come on in hi Eleanor I'm Michael how
are you today I'm great thanks for
asking oh one question where am I who
are you and what's going on right so you
Eleanor shell Straub are dead your life
on Earth has ended and you are now in
the next phase of your existence in the
universe cool cool
I have some questions don't you mind how
did I die I I don't remember
yes in cases of traumatic or
embarrassing deaths we erase the memory
to allow for a peaceful transition are
you sure you want to hear all right so
you were in a grocery store parking lot
you dropped a bottle of something called
lonely gal margarita mix for one and
when you bent down to pick it up a long
column of shopping carts they were being
returned to the shopping cart collection
area rolled out of control and plowed
right into him oof that's how I died no
sorry there's more would you were able
to grab on to the front of the column of
shopping carts but it swept you right
out into the street where you were
struck and killed by a mobile billboard
truck advertising an erectile
dysfunction pill called engorge allayed
funnily enough the first EMT to arrive
was an ex-boyfriend okay I get it thank
you so who is right I mean about all of
this well let's say Hindus are a little
bit right Muslims a little bit Jews
Christians Buddhists every religion
guessed about 5% except for Doug for
said who's Doug Forsyth well Doug was a
STONER kid who lived in Calgary during
the 1970s one night he got really high
on mushrooms and his best friend Randy
said hey what do you think happens after
we die and Doug has launched into this
long monologue where he got like 92%
correct and we couldn't believe what we
were hearing
that's him actually right up there he's
pretty famous around here
I'm very lucky
have that so maybe my biggest question
am i I mean is this or well it's not the
heaven or hell idea that you were raised
on but generally speaking in the
afterlife there's a good place and
there's a bad place you're in the good
place
you're okay owner here in the good place
well that's good
sure is okay let's take a walk shall we
oh did I have a purse no I'm dead right
okay
you